Speaker 1: I know that these stories have become
exhausting, but it is important to keep them
in the public spotlight. Another one of these
anti-vaccine so-called Christians has died of
COVID. And this is not just an anti-vaccine
Christian. This is someone who was pushing
ivermectin and pushing hydroxychloroquine.
The New York Times reports that Marcus Lamb,
a Christian broadcaster and vaccine skeptic, has
died of COVID. This was the co-founder of the
Daystar Television Network. Over the years, we've
played lots of wacky clips of non empirically
based claims from shows on the Daystar network.
Marcus Lamb, Christian broadcaster in Dallas,
dismissive of COVID vaccinations, died Tuesday
after contracting the virus. Mr. Lamb was 64,
frequently suggested on his Christian TV network
that people pray instead of getting inoculated. He
had to be rushed to the hospital when his oxygen
levels dropped, quote all of a sudden after he
contracted the virus. Mr. Lamb's wife and son
confirmed his death on Tuesday on ministry now.
The show the couple hosted. It was not immediately
clear when he tested positive or where he died.
The network did not respond to requests for
comment. He hosted a bunch of different shows.
Daystar broadcasters, including the labs,
repeatedly questioned the efficacy of the vaccine
on May 10th. They said that the vaccine could be
killing your immune system. That's false. We want
to warn you, we want to help. You will want to
give you an alternative. What was the alternative?
Well, instead of getting vaccinated quote, we
can pray. We can get ivermectin and budesonide
and hydroxychloroquine. Those drugs are not
approved for COVID treatment by the FDA.
He also denounced vaccination mandates for
schoolchildren. On November 18th, Mrs Lam said
her husband contracted the virus after she had
he had diabetes, which exacerbated his symptoms.
Last month, Jonathan Lam, the son, said his
father's COVID battle was the result of a
spiritual attack from the enemy, folks.
How do we react to this right? I mean,
believe the vaccine said the
vaccine killed your immune system,
believed that getting COVID is a spiritual attack
from the enemy. Suggested prayer and ivermectin
and hydroxychloroquine as a treatment. Incredible
damage potential that this individual has done.
And now he's dead of COVID. What's our reaction?
I know people like the eggman feel nothing but
pleasure at the fact that
this individual has died.
I still have a very hard time gloating about the
death of anybody, but I think the message here is
not only was his message potentially damaging to
people who watched this drivel. It may have also
been what led to him dying as well. And maybe we
leave it there. Maybe there isn't more to say, but
another one? You know, and it's it's emotionally
exhausting. It's exhausting from a public health
standpoint. But these anti-vax Christians
and right wingers who have media presences,
they continue to die, and it doesn't seem
like it's going to stop anytime soon.